okay so the topic of this video is going
to be some of the basic differences in
how organisms get their energy there's
two broad categories of how organisms
get their energy on earth organisms are
either called heterotrophs or autotrophs
all life needs energy but how they get
their energy is a little different from
one another so let's start with the
autotrophs so autotrophs when you look
at the basic definition of an autotroph
they're organisms that can make their
own energy now there's two kinds of
autotrophs however one of them were more
familiar with and one might be a little
mysterious so the first type of
autotroph I'd like to mention are called
the photoautotrophs and these are the
ones that use sunlight to do
photosynthesis plants are a great
example in the animation you see
sunlight you now also see carbon dioxide
gas and now you also see water these are
the three basic ingredients in a very
complex chemical reaction called
photosynthesis and at the end of
photosynthesis what the plant releases I
think we know they release a life-giving
gas called oxygen but that's not the
reason why plants and other
photoautotrophs
do photosynthesis they do photosynthesis
because they're making their energy
they're making their food they make
glucose which is a type of sugar and so
photosynthesis is how organisms like
photoautotrophs like plants feed
themselves so plants are probably the
most obvious example of photoautotrophs
but there are others there are other
organisms that do photosynthesis let's
not forget there are some bacteria
called cyanobacteria that are
photosynthetic autotroph and others
algae algae are photosynthetic
autotrophs in the picture these are
called diatoms or die atoms however you
would like to pronounce them and then
there's the second kind of autotroph the
chemoautotrophs and these are typically
bacteria and and not all bacteria but
some bacteria and they do a process
called chemosynthesis and they still
produce their own food they still
produce
their own energy they just don't use
sunlight they use chemicals chemicals
such as methane are involved in a fairly
complex chemical reaction and the
product what's created is energy for
them to use so
autotrophs whether they're
photoautotrophs or chemoautotrophs
autotrophs are often called producers
since they produce the energy of an
ecosystem here is a food chain and you
can see that the plants at the bottom
make energy for the insects and that
energy moves up and up and up and up and
up the food chain well what about the
heterotrophs
so the heterotrophs are kind of just the
opposite these are organisms that cannot
make their own energy through
photosynthesis or through chemo
synthesis so they find ways to get
energy in other means and so we're going
to go over the different kinds of
consumers here's a wolf as a great
example of a consumer you'll see another
example involving a wolf in a moment so
one of the one of the more cute adorable
herbivores rabbits are a great example
because they are called herbivores
because they only eat plant another kind
would be carnivores here we have some
wolves on a hunt and so carnivores like
wolves only eat other animals and then
there's the organisms that will eat
plants or in organisms that eat plants
or animals are called omnivores bears
bears are a great example
they'll eat fish they'll eat berries
they'll eat fruits they'll eat other
animals and so they're a great example
of omnivores humans humans are a great
example of omnivores is one and then
there's the other kind of heterotroph
that we don't usually consider these are
the decomposers when organisms die there
are nutrients still left in that
organisms body and decomposers will
obtain nutrients from dead organisms and
eventually cause the organism to decay
couple categories of decomposers the
first are the decompose is called the
detritivores and like the earthworm the
picture of the earthworm detritivores
ingest in
feed on on nutrients from dead organisms
however the other category of decompose
the other category of decomposes are
called saprophyte they don't ingest they
don't have mouths they don't have a
stomach but they absorb they release
enzymes and to whatever it is they're
growing and then they absorb those
nutrients directly into their cells and
these are called saprophyte smush rooms
and fungus or a great example of
saprophyte s-- so whether the organism
feeds directly or indirectly whether the
hetero trough feeds directly on plants
or indirectly for instance the Frog gets
its energy indirectly from the plant
because the Frog would eat the insect
which ate another insect which ate a
plant so all life directly or indirectly
relies on autotrophs for energy so
that's it that's really the end of this
video but please stay tuned I would like
to acknowledge some of the photographers
who made some of these images possible
next I would like to thank and
acknowledge some of the photographer's
that allowed the use of their images for
this video without their their graphics
and their visuals I don't think the
video would be hit as as intriguing so
thank you very much
you